o psol heloisa mais um vídeo e hoje eu
vou ensinar como fazer uma máquina de
fazer bolhas de sabão
para isso vamos à fides pneus mas se
vocês não tiverem podem usar argolas de
pvc por fazer básicos a este pedaço de
madeira porém se vocês não tiverem podem
usar bonito picolé ou então podem usar
cartão para estudarem cartão tem que
passar uma camada de cola por cima para
deixar tudo à prova d'água por fazer a
roda vou utilizar quatro fim de pneus
porém se vocês quiserem que a nossa
máquina faça mais bolhas só continuará a
enfrentar de forma simétrica por gerar
esta roda usar uma rolha de cortiça fez
um furo no centro e depois coloquei como
eixo um espeto de madeira e se estirar
como um peão significa que está tudo
mais ou menos balançadas por prender o
sta rosa que fizemos anteriormente
utilizaram pedaços caneta com 10
centímetros e o curta e usando uma serra
para metal
vocês podem ver é só colocar nesta parte
do condutor tenha força para gerar esta
roda grande vamos precisar fazer uma
polia com 600 de bianco exterior e cinco
centímetros de diâmetro interior
faça um furo no centro da polia comer um
diâmetro que vocês usaram para hoje cola
nesta partida tranquilizando super cola
e se desejarem podem colocar mais
policiais por ter mais opções de
velocidade como eixo do motor era muito
pequeno e oitenta e um pedaço de tubo
com 400 desta forma quando vocês tenham
motor seja muito fraco e o conselho que
vocês passam uma polia maior ou seja em
vez de ter uma polícia com seis
centímetros passa uma polia com 10 do
centro e dessa forma a velocidade vai
ser transformada em força por fazer ela
escuta a extremidade do fim da
disciplina mais ou menos 30 graus usando
uma serra para metal
de seguida acrescenta e três pedaços com
5.900 sem títulos e ficção utilizando
supercopa por gerar eles utilizaram um
tutor que eu tirei de uma impressora
velha porque a máquina eficiente você
tem que colocar ventoinha perto da roda
que está na frente
se você estiver em um trator em casa por
usar porém eu vou ensinar como fazer um
tradutor bastante simples que pode ser
usado com o comandante e um cervo para
ativar a máquina à distância por
movimentar os motores vou transar uma
bateria de 9 volts
porém se vocês não tiverem conector
basta ter a estampar uma outra bateria
para ser mais fácil entender a ligação
dos cabos eu fiz este ano aqui basta
vocês colocarem pausa e seguirem as
cores se vocês não tiverem máquina para
soldar nos preocupa vocês podem
simplesmente enrolar os cabos
manualmente que vai funcionar também
para quem tiver um sistema s em casa
basta colocar um cervo aqui e vai
permitir ligar a máquina à distância
desta forma vocês vão conseguir pregar
partidas algumas pessoas e produz altos
ganhos o fim eu espero que vocês tenham
gostado deste projeto aqui deixe nos
comentários sugestões de coisas que
vocês gostariam que eu fizesse com os
restantes pinas é isso muito obrigado
até a próxima